il s'empare à la tuque était plein de
nouveaux copains avec cette émission
finalement ils sont très bien
1 ils sont tenus le dis pas ici est très
bien comme si tu m'a annoncé la mort de
quelqu'un non parce qu'on peut se mêle à
vendre la chanson déjà je peux je vais
montrer au sérieux je veux dire ils ont
comme ça ils sont ils font ça très bien
c'est vraiment ils sont ils sont très
bien qu'ils sont émus ils sont contents
et ça donne pas envie de faire de la
plaisanterie là dessus voilà grave c'est
que c'est grave sans déconner ça je hais
les chanteurs de la jeunesse et la
passion la jeunesse et la passion que
met ces jeunes gens à leur métier c'est
on était très important donc je suis
content de voir les parrainer chez j'ai
tiré ce soir alan pascal ne s'est pas
contenté de donner votre chance il vous
donne aussi des conseils alors justement
on va tous en profitent et pascal quels
conseils donneriez-vous à un jeune
chanteur qui débute d'abord une
détermination formidable c'est l'idée
qu'on ne veut faire ça et rien d'autre
deuxième chose ne surtout pas s'occuper
d'être à la mode parce que là c'est raté
comme un appui à peu près dans toute
l'histoire de la chanson française
mais ils sont à l'abri de ça suffit je
veux mais je retiens ma phrase parce que
sans ça je finis ma phrase il s'agit des
jeunes gens moi j'en ai rien à faire je
ne viens pas faire le bus ici je finis
ma phrase et je hais je vous dis que il
n'y a pas d'exemple quasiment de vedette
de music hall de la chanson française
qui ont qui sont arrivés en semoule en
se couchant dans la mode voilà alors
vous ne posez une question j'essaie je
vous réponds du peloton voix oscille
donc l'idée simplement ne pas se gavent
aller courir pas savoir dans la mode
parce que le temps ne la rattrape et
elle est déjà passé d'accord quels
conseils donneriez vous à un vieux
chanteur qui débute encore d'être en
bonne santé du chanteur toujours temps
parce que il faut il faut pas employer
ces jeunes ces adjectifs qui review vous
allez être bientôt que je ne suis donc
pas bien quels conseils donneriez-vous à
pascal sevran jeune je donnerai un
conseil à pascal sevran
à cette heure ci doit être couché
bonsoir il pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu